[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just talk to the kid you're magic like
me I need as you listen to me the
world's hungry place and dark place
hi there I only met two or three people
like us they died
when I was a kid I bumped into these
things
I don't know about magic eye I was
called at the shining
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes I used to live here
won't you come in it's the least I can
do is it like you remember cleaner yeah
well you feel free to look around while
I get the water boil in your hair is
[Music]
there you go thank you
awesome music I do apologize
it gets so very hot here this time of
year it's fine
what do you feel like you could just
about die but you know what they say
about dairy hmm no one who dies here
ever really dies
but tell me how is it being back in
Derry it's got a strange strange oh my I
had some cookies in the oven before you
came Steve right there I shouldn't
impose I'm gonna no no no no no I insist
we photos are lovely miss Kirsch are
these your family my father came to this
country with $14 in his pocket
what did he do mrs. Kirsch my father
joined the circus
I was always daddy's little girl what
about you are you still his little girl
Beverly are you
[Music]
smear the losers club is officially
begun
[Music]
I wasn't doing this but you have to
stick together
[Music]
hello
I almost forgot to show you guys what I
found this morning that's a short kid
I am going to take you to a place that
no tourists would ever find in a million
years chance of a lifetime
[Music]
[Music]
sanaya
they make human sacrifices here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
I can't believe that in half an hour I
will be a part of the the Domus gaming
dynasty Empire Dominion we prefer
Dominion yeah I honestly can't wait to
be a part of your banners there's just
one more thing
and then you are officially part of the
family so at midnight get to play game
why it's just something we do when
someone new joins the family a game what
game
I didn't think are you really gonna play
that Wow the rules are simple you can
hide anywhere we then try to find you so
there's no way for me to win right and
stay hidden don't holler
no thank you good luck what the hell is
this how old is this thing
I know you're in here sweetheart
you shot the maid she look like she's
wearing a giant white wedding dress
Emily themed I had to play off so that I
can get you out they think that the clay
before sunrise or something very bad
will happen to the family if we don't
find her and perform the ritual we're
all dead
found her
and today's video is called getting to
know your crossbow I forgot my gun why
don't you just use mine
that's real Adamas I just saw her just
another sacrifice
yes I didn't see where to get married
[Music]
I told you that I want to go to that
festival in Sweden no you said it would
be cool to go yeah and then I got the
opportunity and I decided to do it you
going I just wish he would have told me
that's all dude she needs a therapist
you've been wanting out of this stupid
relationship for like a year now and
don't forget about all of the beautiful
Swedish women you'll need in June ok
guys that's not her again seriously babe
what's happening Danny
I was so very sorry to hear about what
happened
I invited Danny to come to Sweden you
know what she's been going for Christian
says you've got this special week
planned it's sort of a crazy festival
special ceremonies and dressing up
things fun
unbelievable welcome a happy midsummer
school what time is it 9:00 p.m. that
can't be right the sky is blue this is
what 9 p.m. was like here how long have
you two been together just over three
and a half years four years really yeah
what do you think it's like another
world tomorrow's a big day is it scary
what is it
it has special properties what am I
going through
we just need to acclimate I don't want
to acclimate I want to go
absolutely not what is happening you
look so guilty right now because you
know
we only do this every 90 years
I was most excited for you to come
I'm gonna ask you a series of questions
I want you to respond truthfully have
you ever heard someone yes have you ever
experienced anything you'd consider
abnormal
[Music]
yes last question do you know how
mutants are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous adult ones they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Music]
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why you're here
[Music]
what is this place she's in the hospital
haunted house
[Applause]
[Music]
you're being through hot get some rest
[Music]
[Applause]
this town has told stories horrible
stories but they don't realize I have
scary stories of my own sir pillows tell
me a story
[Music]
sara bellows this book the stories write
themselves
it all comes alive you don't read the
book the book reads you
I'm afraid of it inside
the next everything you see in here is
either haunted cursed or has been used
in some kind of ritualistic practice
nothing's a toy it's safer for these
things to be in here than out there
sometimes it's better to keep the genie
in the bottle don't your parents keep
any creepy stuff around you keep it all
locked away in a room so we're safe it's
not really good for anyone to go in
there
[Music]
don't you do to get in there
[Music]
I think you have the wrong house there's
no Annabelle here this is the don't it's
a beacon for other spirits
[Music]
[Music]